[Musique]
Arnaud Mondbourg. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Et bien, je suis né à Clamsy dans la
Nièvre en 1962.
Mon père était inspecteur des impôts. Ma
mère professeure d'espagnol.
Je suis j'ai fait l'essentiel de ma vie,
ma première vie de d'adolescent,
d'étudiants
dans ma région natale, la Bourgogne.
J'ai passé l'essentiel de ma mon cursus
universitaire à la faculté de droit de
Dijon. Puis ensuite, j'ai été reçu à
Sciencepo Paris en 1983
ou 4 peut-être 3. Et euh ensuite après
mon service militaire, je suis entré au
barreau de Paris. Je suis devenu avocat
pendant 7 ans. En 1997, j'avais 34 ans.
Euh, j'ai été élu député de Sonéloire
dans la région Bourgogne
euh où je suis né, où j'ai vécu. Un de
mes grands-pères, grand-père Henry
Mondbourg, tenait une boucherie
charcuterie à Hautin en Sonloir
et depuis les années 20. Et donc, il y
avait comme une sorte de filiation
naturelle
euh à m'y présenter. J'ai été lu trois
fois pendant 15 ans.
Puis en 2012, je suis entré au
gouvernement de monsieur Hollande où je
suis devenu ministre du redressement
productif chargé
de l'industrie, du commerce, de
l'artisanat, du numérique, puis ministre
de l'économie 2 ans plus tard et puis
j'ai quitté le gouvernement sur des
désaccords assez importants euh au mois
d'août 2014. Depuis je me suis formé
dans une école de commerce que je rêvais
de faire lorsque j'avais 20 ans,
l'INEAD. Mon père m'avait dit "Écoute,
on n pas les moyens de te payer cette
école, donc va bosser." Et donc c'est à
50 ans que j'ai recommencé à zéro ma
vie. Je suis devenu euh entrepreneur.
J'ai créé
six entreprises depuis euh dans
l'agroalimentaire notamment, enfin dans
l'agriculture, nous créons des marques
équitables
et euh je me présente devant vous en
homme heureux
et libre.
Ah ça libre c'est sûr.
Alors on va parler un petit peu
géopolitique, finance, terrorisme
hacking peut-être, mais surtout. Est-ce
que vous avez vu notre vidéo de Frédéric
Perucci ?
Oui, je l'ai regardé avec beaucoup
d'attention. D'abord parce que euh
monsieur Pierucci euh est un homme qui a
payé très cher euh finalement son
patriotisme économique
et son patriotisme d'entreprise.
Deuxièmement,
euh il a eu la le courage d'affronter
un État puissant que sont les États-Unis
d'Amérique. Il n'a été aidé finalement
que par peu d'institutions. certainement
pas son entreprise qui l'a abandonné en
race campagne
et donc j'ai beaucoup d'estime pour
lui-même son parcours,
son tempérament et j'ai admiré la
solidité avec laquelle il a il a
recouvré sa liberté et son sens de
l'initiative. C'était un haut dirigeant
d'Alstom et il a parfaitement expliqué
les tenailles
euh de cette espèce de de prise d'otage
dans laquelle il a été
euh euh capturé et qui a conduit pour la
France à la perte d'Alstom.
Je vais je vais je vais vous donner du
monsieur le ministre. Monsieur le
ministre, est-ce qu'on peut parler
intelligence économique ? Est-ce qu'on
peut parler renseignement économique ?
Est-ce que la France est suffisamment
endurcie pour affronter les
comportements prédateurs de nos anciens
alliés ?
C'est une question à la fois lucide et
provocatrice que vous posez là.
Lucide parce que à l'évidence non.
à chaque fois et il faut regarder un peu
ce qui s'est passé depuis que finalement
la France est ouverte, depuis que les
grandes entreprises ont été
reprivatisées à peu près les années fin
des années 80, début des années 90 et
donc elles ont été la proie prise de
contrôle par des investisseurs
étrangers. Ça a commencé avec Péchinet.
Péchinet était le leader mondial de
l'aluminium. Faisait travailler des
dizaines pour ne pas dire des centaines
de milliers de Français. euh
euh de voilà et d'étranger euh autour de
ces installations de fabrication de
l'aluminium de l'ensemble de la filière
qui était intégrée et y compris la
fabrication de ses propres outils de
travail.
péchinet a été interdite par l'Union
européenne
à l'époque de faire une prise de
contrôle
sur une entreprise concurrente et c'est
l'entreprise concurrente qui a pris
péchinet, l'a coupé en morceaux, l'a
revendu à la sauvette et à la découpe et
nous avons perdu péchinet. Il reste
deux usines qu'on appelle des smelters.
C'est les usines qui fabriquent par
réaction chimique l'aluminium. une à
Dquerkque et une à Saint-Jean de
Morienne. Je me souviens qu'au
gouvernement, on en a sauvé une sur le
fil
à Saint-Jean de Morienne, mais eu
beaucoup de perte et d'abandon à la
suite de cette finalement interdiction
par l'Union européenne de d'acheter les
autres et euh de transformation
finalement de cette entreprise qui était
leader euh euh européen et mondial.
Euh donc pour les Européens trop
puissante curieusement et donc elle est
devenue la proie d'investisseur. Après
il y a eu Arcelor.
a fait l'objet d'une opéa inamicale par
Mital,
un britannique,
non pas indien mais britannique qui a
pris le contrôle de Mital et qui de
pardon d'Arscelor et qui a finalement
privilégié toujours son activité minière
plutôt que son activité de
transformation
du minerai en métal et en métallurgie et
en cidérurgie. Et donc nous avons eu à
déplorer à peu près sous tous les
quinquenas euh des prises de décision de
défaisance, de fermeture d'usine.
Sarkozi a eu Gandrange, Hollande a eu
Florenge et ça va continuer. Le prochain
sur la liste est connu, c'est Faus sur
Mè. Et donc euh quand on confie les clés
d'une grande entreprise à capacité
mondiale, transnational et au minimum
européenne
à des décideurs qui n'ont aucun lien
avec le territoire français, n'ont aucun
intérêt avec l'histoire et la géographie
française, le résultat est toujours le
même. Je peux continuer la Litanie ? Euh
ensuite nous
avant avant avant de continuer la
Litanie, je vais vous reposer ma
question.
Mais c'est une litanie malheureusement.
Ma question était sur les questions de
renseignement économique, d'intelligence
économique, on en est où pour protéger
les entreprise française ?
Mais vous voyez bien que la question
ne se pose même pas en terme de
renseignement économique. Pourquoi ?
Parce que les renseignements tout le
monde les a. Il suffit de lire internet
pour savoir ce qui se prépare
sur telle ou telle entreprise. Il suffit
de regarder les choses et de les
analyser froidement. Les analystes même
donnent les informations. Donc c'est pas
du renseignement économique, c'est du
courage politique dont nous manquons.
Renseignement économique,
c'est pas très compliqué. Il y a pas
besoin d'avoir fait polytechnique pour
comprendre que nous sommes dans une
guerre économique et que les États
s'ados aux entreprises multinationales
qui ont des racines dans ces nations
État ou État nation et que elles
construisent des stratégies de prise de
contrôle. Et donc c'est pas très
compliqué de comprendre que nous sommes
nous-mêmes avec des entreprises qui ont
une taille certes mondiale mais petite
par rapport aux entreprises qui sont
rattachées aux deux grands empires, la
Chine et l'Amérique. Nous voyons bien
que nous sommes vulnérables.
Donc la stratégie qui devrait consister
à construire des conglomérats européens
ou des conglomérats franco-français que
nous pourrions faire, c'est-à-dire
renforcé par plusieurs métiers. un
métier quand il est seul pour éviter des
prises de contrôle et avoir des niveaux
de euh consolidation capitalistique qui
nous permettre d'échapper à la proie, à
être au prédateur, à devenir une proie.
C'est ça que je voulais dire. Et en
vérité euh le renseignement économique
est totalement inopérant de ce point de
vue-là. C'est-à-dire
s'enoccupe en France.
Normalement, c'est le premier ministre
qui est chargé de ça. C'est une mission
interministérielle auprès du premier
ministre. C'est lui qui est chargé de
collecter les informations, de se
préoccuper des manœuvres qui pourraient
concerner nos entreprises. Mais vous
savez les manœuvres qui concernent nos
entreprises quand on les a perdu,
Alstom, Technip, Lafarge, Alcatel,
c'était les quatre autres dans la
Litanie que je vous voulais vous
proposer de développer. Ces entreprises
là, c'est d'abord leurs dirigeants le
problème,
c'est eux qui vont se vendre qui
touchent d'ailleurs les bénéfices de
cette bente.
Chèque à l'appui,
retrait de chapeau garantie,
ce qui est arrivé à monsieur Cron à la
tête d'Alstom, ce qui est arrivé à la à
monsieur Pilinco à la tête de Technipp.
Voilà, je crois même que le président de
la Farge qui était français qui a vendu
à HSIM, nous aurions pu faire tout autre
chose. Ils aurons pu faire une alliance
Alstom Mitsubishi. Nous aurrions pu
imaginer par exemple une alliance ou une
prise de contrôle par Saint-Gobin de la
Farge. On aurait eu dans le BTP, c'était
pas absurde le ciment et le vert,
c'était pas absurde. C'est des métiers
voisins, c'est des marchés à peu près
communs. On aurait pu imaginer ça. Ouig
et et
ou je ne sais quel autre. Donc on peut
construire des stratégies alternatives.
Le problème c'est que les dirigeants
que nous avons font leur coup en douce
euh et quand ils ont par exemple, comme
c'était le cas technique, l'État à leur
capital, euh ils arrivent à convaincre
l'État. C'est ça qui est incroyable.
Quand techniqu, prenons cet exemple,
c'est quand même une entreprise de pas
loin de 100000 salariés dans le monde.
C'est une des cotations du CAC 40. C'est
le spécialiste français
euh euh du pétrole qui est né de
l'Institut français du pétrole qui a été
créé par le général de Gaulle avec tous
les brevets de la recherche sur le
forage pétrolier.
Payé avec nos impôts.
Oui, exactement. Bah les contribuables
ont tous ont tous participé peu au prou.
La cirugurie l'ont sauvé plusieurs fois.
Alst ils l'ont nationalisé une fois. euh
la F ont donné les marchés publics,
Alstom des marchés publics. Donc oui,
c'est sans l'État, il n'y a pas ces
entreprises et c'est un bien qu'il y ait
une alliance entre le public et le
privé. Et donc quand nous nous sommes
retrouvés avec cette entreprise
technique qui a inventé l'idée qu'il
fallait acheter faire une fusion entrego
avec FMC qui est une boîte Texane qui
fait des choses à peu près similaires et
complémentaires
euh américaine.
cette entreprise FMC était en difficulté
mais ils ont trouvé quand même le moyen
d'aller chez Goldman Sax qui a fait une
attestation pour expliquer que c'était
une entreprise qui valait à peu près la
même chose que Techni
avec une fausse fusion entrega et en
vérité FMC a coulé et a mis en
difficulté technique. Donc aller
demander aux ingénieurs, au cadre, à la
défense ce qu'ils pensent de cette
opération. Avec un déménagement du siège
social à Houston,
l'essentiel des fonctions de direction
été transféré et la propriété
de cette entreprise nous a échappé.
Et vous avez dans ce dans ce conseil
d'administration, vous avez quand même
la BPI, l'Institut français du pétrole.
Il y a une personne qui s'est opposée
dans le vote. Tous les autres ont vu
leur rémunération augmenter, y compris
les représentants de la BPI. Donc il y a
juste un petit problème. Donc vous me
parlez de renseignement économique. Moi,
j'ai envie de vous dire il y a juste un
problème de loyauté.
Euh
ou mais si si on si on a des taupes
parce que si si c'est des taupes
déloyales,
il faut que nos renseignements puissent
voir ne soient pas aveuglé. Si je vous
dis Robert Guillaum, ça vous parle ?
Robert Guillaume ? Pas du tout.
Tuattends
si je vous dis Philippe Caduc,
je connais pas
la dite, ça vous parle ?
Ah oui, bien sûr. La dit, oui, oui.
La dite, c'est quoi ?
Bah, c'est une agence qui s'occupe de
pour la diffusion d'information
technique,
voilà. Et mais qui aide les entreprises
à l'étranger pour les aider à progresser
à l'étranger. La dite est une très belle
institution et qui marche très bien.
Qui qui est Anatole France d'ailleurs ?
Ma question concernant les services de
renseignement, c'est on a une attitude
agressive sur nos fleurons piloter main
dans la main le gouvernement d'État
américain plus son département de
justice qui vient faire trap un piège
pour le la une de nos entreprises. Nos
services de renseignement ne bougent
pas. Alst met danger notre armée.
La vente d'Alstom met en danger notre
armée. Vous savez pourquoi ? L'armée a
aussi des renseignements. La direction
du renseignement militaire là, est-ce
que à votre avis la direction du
renseignement militaire va s'intéresser
à comment on peut attaquer notre armée
par des mouvements ? Écoutez, ces
décisions euh ces analyses, elles ont
été faites
en tant que en ministre de de
sûr ces analyses, elles ont été faites,
permettez-moi de le dire, on est capable
de de mesurer que quand on on perd la
maîtrise technique sur nos chaudières
nucléaires des bâtiments militaires,
hein, c'estàd qu'en fait, on est entre
les mains d'Américain, on est capable de
dire non. Bon, le ministère de la
défense était avait exprimé sa position
à l'époque de la vente d'Alstom. en
disant attention, il y a un problème.
Très bien. Mais les décisions qui ont
été prises ont été contraires. Donc moi,
j'ai envie de vous dire euh
la chaîne de commandement n'a pas été
respectée.
Non, j'ai envie de vous dire ceux qui
ont pris cette décision, c'est le
président de la République de l'époque,
François Hollande et son premier
ministre, puisque c'était mes chefs, euh
je crois on ont pris une décision
lourde conséquence et fâcheuse et et
condamnable et condamnable. Donc moi,
j'étais contre euh j'ai perdu euh à
l'arbitrage, on a rattrapé après les
choses, mais en fait euh euh je pense
qu'il ne fallait pas vendre cette cette
entreprise mais tous les éléments
étaient sur la table.
Donc euh on peut pas dire qu'il ait pas
eu éclairage
de de l'esprit de nos dirigeants.
Est-ce qu'on peut appeler un chat ? Un
chat. Est-ce que ces personnes ont fait
preuve de
nonchalance ? Est-ce que ces personnes
ont fait preuve de forfaiture ? Est-ce
que ces personnes ont fait preuve de
quoi d'ailleurs ? De courage.
Moi, je dirais que c'est d'abord le
conformisme.
On s'oppose pas aux Américains
premièrement. Deuxièmement, on va pas se
mettre à dos
la presse.
Puis troisièmement,
à quoi bon et pourquoi faire ? Qu'est-ce
que ça nous rapporte d'aller beauté les
fesses un américain ? Et je c'est comme
ça que ça s'est décidé. Pour moi, c'est
de la euh c'est de l'inconséquence
et euh on n pas très loin de
l'incompétence. Je vais vous dire
pourquoi. Euh une fois, il y a eu un
président de la République qui a dit non
euh aux Américains à l'ONUUS, c'était
monsieur Chirac avec monsieur de
Villepin.
J'étais très fier d'être citoyen de ce
pays. J'étais député à l'époque, voyez.
et j'ai applaudi la décision qui a été
prise. Ça a coûté très cher à à la
France mais c'était une décision qu'il
fallait prendre et elle nous est
aujourd'hui remerciée par le monde
entier qui sait que la France est
capable de dire non. Donc cette
tradition là, elle s'est malheureusement
perdue et je le regrette parce que ça a
des conséquences sur les ouvriers
français, les cadres, les ingénieurs,
les territoires. Ça a des conséquences y
compris sur la maîtrise technologique de
d'un certain nombre de
capacités pas seulement militaire mais
aussi civile. maîtriser des capacités
énergétiques de produire de production
énergétique est fondamental pour un pays
comme le nôtre dans les énergies
renouvelables, dans les réseaux, dans le
nucléaire,
dans
l'ensemble des capacités de production
énergétique, que soit la vapeur ou même
le gaz. Donc tous ces éléments-là euh on
ne s'en est pas soucié parce qu'on
considérait que euh c'était une sorte de
faux bon sens qui devait conduire à euh
vendre. D'ailleurs, ça continue. Moi,
j'ai entendu l'actuel ministre de
l'économie dire sur ce qui restait
d'Alston, c'est la partie de transport
ferroviaire, il faut faire un accord
avec Simens et les Allemands. C'est pas
en soit une mauvaise idée, mais en
vérité c'était une nouvelle vente. Et
quel était l'argument qu'on prenait ? On
disait "Mais les Chinois sont très
forts, donc faut tout vendre. Alors, si
les Chinois sont forts, on doit tout
vendre, bah nous serons encore plus
faibles. Donc, il faut juste, je crois,
mesurer les rapports de force,
construire une stratégie industrielle de
long terme. Moi, je suis favorable à ce
qui est euh une sorte de fil rouge
transpartisan sur les questions
industrielles de guerre économique parce
qu'on peut pas avoir des politiques qui
divergent à chaque changement électoral,
c'est pas possible. Euh cette
construction-là, il a fallu des
générations pour monter ces grandes
entreprises, pour maîtriser cette
science et cette technologie, former des
générations d'ingénieurs et de
techniciens de et d'ouvriers. Et ça part
comme ça en fumée en par des décisions
inconséquentes et qui pour moi sont
essentiellement imprégnés de l'acheter.
Donc on vous appelle le vendredi soir
pour la vente le dimanche matin, c'est
ça ?
Vous parlez de guerre économique, vous
parlez de défense ? Est-ce que le
ministère de la Défense est impliqué
dans la guerre économique ?
Euh vous savez que le ministère de la
défense
dépense ou gère, je crois, si ma mémoire
est bonne, 16 milliards de dépenses
militaires qui ont des conséquences
industrielles. C'est le premier
ministère de l'industrie en France,
ministère de la défense. Donc c'est pas
euh un petit ministère.
Euh et dans euh je me souviens que dans
dans les décisions interministérielles,
l'évocation du dossier, la défense était
réticente et avait exprimé des positions
de réticence. Mais comme vous savez,
c'est le président de la République qui
est le chef des armées. Donc c'est lui
qui décide pour le compte du ministère
de la défense. Donc voilà la la
conséquence de ce que ce type de
décision remonte
toujours en haut sur des intérêts qui
pour moi
sont mélangés ou matiné de toutes sortes
de considérations, parfois même
politicienne, mais très peu de nature
stratégique pour défendre les intérêts
de notre pays.
Je je viens à ma deuxième question.
Est-ce que vous pensez que notre comment
vous la formulez ? Est-ce que vous
pensez que notre chaîne de commandement
industrielle
est vérolé par des gens travaillants
pour des puissances étrangères ?
Bah écoutez, moi je suis frappé de voir
que d'abord les dirigeants de ces
entreprises,
la première chose, le premier réflex
qu'ils ont, c'est de vendre et puis eux
de faire la culbute personnelle. Donc
d'abord ce problème là, après il y a
leur conseil d'administration. Conseil
d'administration
dans le dossier Alstom, le conseil
d'administration avait été verrouillé
par Patrick Cron par avance. Donc il
s'était obligé à voter queles que soient
les circonstances avec monsieur Cron
contre monnaie sonante et trébuchante.
Dans le dossier technique,
la BPI et l'Institut français du pétrole
ont approuvé la transaction.
Faut le faire quand même. C'est c'est
quand même nos brevets qu'on a donné aux
Américains.
Et le dirigeant, monsieur Pilino, a
touché l'échec aussi. Et les membres du
conseil d'administration. Donc là, il y
a un problème,
c'est légal.
Ah bah c'est la loi. Oui, mais c'est il
y a un problème de moralisation et puis
de de question patriotique. C'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle j'ai
arraché quand j'étais à Bersi décret que
la presse a a affublé de mon nom qui
s'appelle le décret du 14 mai 2014 qui
permet au ministre de l'économie sans
contrein écoutez bien sans contrein de
bloquer tout investissement étranger
dans une vente à caractère stratégique
dans sep secteurs. l'eau, la santé,
l'énergie, le transport, la défense, les
jeux et je crois les télécommunication.
Donc Alstom, on pouvait bloquer la vente
en disant c'est non, comme le font
d'ailleurs la quasi-totalité des grandes
puissances. Les Chinois n'en parlons
pas, c'est obligatoire, faut passer sous
les fourges codines du Parti communiste
chinois. Et les Américains, on passe par
le Cfius. Le CFIUS, c'est un organisme
qui est présidé par le président des
États-Unis lui-même avec 500 personnes
qui instruisent tous les dossiers tous
les jours d'investisseurs étrangers sur
le sol américain et qui euh ont pris je
crois en en année, il y a en 2017 pardon
en 2000
2014 avait pris 123 vetaux sur les
investissements étrangers aux
États-Unis. Si mes souvenirs sont bons,
peut-être je me trompe sur le G, mais on
n pas bien loin.
123 véau et en plaçant des conditions.
Par exemple, vous avez le droit de
racheter cette entreprise à ton
technologique mais c'est nous qui
choisissons le PDG, le conseil
administrati soit composé à 100 %
d'Américain. Le siège social ne pourra
pas être délocalisé, sinon la vente est
annulée.
Ça, c'est les Américains, pays euh
inventeur du capitalisme libéral. C'est
pas le Venezuela.
C'est pas le Venezuela. Il y a parfois
plus de soleil qu'au Venezuela.
Alors, je vous dis ça parce que
ce décret aurait permis de bloquer la
vente de Technipp,
aurait permis bloquer la vente d'Alstom
et nous aurait permis de conserver ça.
Et non seulement on l'a pas, le ministre
de l'économie ne l'a pas bloqué, mais de
surcroix, il a laissé la BPI, la banque
publique
d'investissement que nous avons créé,
qui est au conseil d'administration pour
défendre les intérêts stratégiques de la
France, même contre la corruption
supposée ou présumée de son dirigeant
parce que c'est quand même ça. L'intérêt
de la France prime doit primer avant
toute autre. Et s'il y a la BPI dans les
conseils administration, c'est pour ça.
Alors là, ça n'a eu aucune incidence.
Donc moi, je m'interroge.
Le ministre de l'époque, c'était qui ?
Je crois que c'était un certain Emmanuel
Macron.
Quand vous êtes parti de votre
ministère, vous avez dit "De mémoire
quand on on arrive plus à faire la
comédie, il faut savoir quitter la
scène."
C'est ce que j'ai fait. Oui, je savais
plus faire ben si vous voulez, je savais
plus mentir. Je vais pas passé ma vie à
raconter des histoires aux français, à
moi-même, à mes enfants déjà et aux
citoyens. Donc quand on n'est pas
d'accord, on a deux solutions. Quand on
n'est pas d'accord, on se tait et on
raconte quelque chose dans lequel on ne
croit pas ou alors on dit la vérité et
on s'en va. C'est ce que j'ai fait.
Voilà, la vérité. Euh voilà, sur les
politiques ont été menées par euh
François Hollande Emmanuel Vals à
l'époque, c'était des très mauvaises
décisions. Voilà, donc je l'ai dit,
ils sont comptables de leur décision.
Euh bah oui, le président Hollande n'a
pas pu se représenter, je vous le
rappelle.
Et monsieur Vals
euh est exilé à Barcelone. Donc il y a
une justice finalement.
Non, il y a une justice.
On finit toujours par payer la facture
en politique.
Justice immanente.
Je sais pas. Mais si vous voulez euh on
peut pas euh commettre des actes euh
siamment
contraire à l'intérêt qu'on est censé
défendre et qu'on a en charge.
Comment ça s'appelle ça ? Ça s'appelle
être
un traître.
Bah ça c'est votre mot monsieur.
Donc je vous le laisse le qualifier.
Moi ce que je sais c'est que quand on a
des intérêts en charge et qu'on fait pas
son boulot, on est au minimum un
incompétent.
Je vais vous l'accorder.
Merci monsieur.
Je vous connais pas mais vous pourriez
parfaitement être à ma place et beaucoup
plus éloquent que moi.
Commencez pas.
Revenons à nos chats, à nos moutons.
Alst, on peut encore l'annuler là.
Alors, de quoi s'agit-il ? ce qu'on a
l'organe législatif pour leur dire
maintenant ça suffit,
je vous répond,
vous avez essayé de nous baiser,
on a bien compris votre petit votre
petit cirque, maintenant c'est terminé.
Est-ce qu'on peut leur
Je vais vous dire je vais vous donner la
position euh qui est la mienne que j'ai
déjà exprimé devant une commission
d'enquête au Sénat qui m'a convoqué pour
savoir ce que j'en pensais. J'ai été
convoqué par l'Assemblée nationale, j'ai
été convoqué par le Sénat et je réponds
toujours aux questions sur ce dossier
dont je me sens quand même comptable.
C'est normal de rendre des comptes. Donc
je rendais comptes de mon action. On en
pense du bien, on en pense du mal, c'est
pas grave mais j'en rends compte. Donc
moi, je peux vous dire que on a signé un
accord.
Cet accord, il disait quoi ? Il disait
plusieurs choses. Je voudrais quand même
y revenir cet accord avant de pouvoir
vous répondre. Il disait plusieurs
choses cet accord. disait premièrement
pendant 3 ans interdit de supprimer les
emplois. Deuxièmement,
on va créer trois co-entreprises entre
Alstom et G parce que c'est pas une
absorption, c'est une alliance. Pourquoi
on a fait une alliance ? parce que avec
sa fran dans les moteurs d'avion,
général électrique depuis 1945
a fait en effet une co-entreprise qui
fonctionne parfaitement et qui a
fabriqué l'avion le plus vendu au monde,
pardon, le moteur d'avion le plus vendu
au monde, le CFM 56 qui décolle et
atterrit toutes les 2 secondes dans le
monde quelque part.
Donc ça c'est une coproduction
franco-américaine safran général
électrique. Donc quand on a vu que le
président de la République finalement
ne voulait pas contredire la puissance
américaine,
on a cherché
des outils de négociation pour améliorer
le plus possible l'accord. Donc on s'est
dit bah on va mettre le nucléaire, les
énergies renouvelables. Le nucléaire
parce que c'est notre souveraineté. Les
énergies renouvelables on c'est l'avenir
et les réseaux parce que c'est
structurant un réseau d'électricité et
d'énergie. Donc ça la vapeur, le
charbon, le gaz c'est du fossile. Bon
c'est pas trop grave si ça part mais le
nucléaire, les énergies renouvelables et
les réseaux c'est fondamental. Donc on a
dit bah ça ça va être dans des
co-entreprises à 51 49
51 euh avec des sièges sociaux en
France, des PDG français, un droit de
véto sur le nucléaire. C'est qu'on a
entreposé le milliard d'activités
de euh
de ce qu'on appelle les chaudières
nucléaire que produisait Alstom
euh dans une co-entreprise
avec un membre du gouvernement, enfin un
membre désigné par le gouvernement pour
utiliser tout droit de vétois
prises par cette entreprise.
1 2 3 et j'ai dit à monsieur Hollande,
je dit monsieur le président vous avez
général électrique 250 milliards, alstom
25 milliards. Si on fait une alliance
entre un mastodonde de 250 milliards, un
rhinocérose de 250 milliards et un
moineau de 25 milliards, nous savons qui
aura raison de l'autre à la fin. Donc je
vous demande de nationaliser ce qu'il
restera d'Alstom pour que Alstom ce soit
plus Alstom qui vient de tout vendre à
la découpe et dans notre dos par des
dirigeants corrompus, mais l'État
français qui sera en face de cette
multinationale américaine dans ces trois
co-entreprises.
D'accord. Alors il y a eu un débat au
salon vert de l'Élysée. Il y avait
monsieur Hollande, monsieur Jouillet,
monsieur Macron, les collaborateurs du
président. Il y avait le premier
ministre, le ministre des finances et
moi-même. Voilà le débat. On s'est je me
suis opposé à cette vente et ensuite
quand ils ont dit bah non, on va la
faire, il a fallu trouver les
compensations pour que ce soit
acceptable. Voilà, c'est ça qui s'est
passé.
Ça s'appelle comment le la vaseline ?
Bah l'apparence, ça s'appelle
l'apparence.
Alors, il y avait quand même des
éléments dans cet accord. trois
co-entreprises, la nationalisation de 20
% d'Alstom plus l'interdiction de
licencier pendant 3 ans plus la création
de 1000 emplois et des amendes s
respectaient pas les 1000 emplois créés.
Donc les syndicats s'en souviennent
parce qu'ils ont eu l'accord. L'accord
était rendu public et c'est sur cette
base là qu'on est allé défendre la
position collégiale du gouvernement.
Alors, les trois coent entreprises, on
les a faites mais il y a 1 an, elles ont
été rachetées par général électrique
avec l'autorisation du gouvernement
actuel. Les 1000 emplois euh n'ont pas
été créés, ils en ont détruit 1000.
Les amendes sont sur le point d'être
versé 50 millions. Mais qu'est-ce que 50
millions ? trop peuon
et pour moi cet accord euh après les
déclarations de monsieur Pierouci, le PL
des coupable de monsieur Cron devant le
département of justice des États-Unis,
euh pour moi euh le consentement qu'a
donné la France à vendre Alstom et donc
l'État
a été vicié.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait il a été et y
compris sur le conseil d'administration
d'Alstom. Pourquoi monsieur Cron a vendu
Alstom ? Pourquoi est en tôle ?
Parce que lui-même était visé par des
poursuites aux États-Unis d'Amérique que
un de ses cadres très proches puisque
c'était un N-2 monsieur Piaouci, un de
ses collaborateurs était en prison et
que ils lui ont expliqué que s'il ne
plaidait pas coupable, c'est monsieur
Cron qui ira en prison. tout ça et dans
les minutes de la procédure américaine.
Donc monsieur Cron n'était pas en
situation de devoir librement décider
pour son entreprise et l'État français
encore moins. Donc c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles il y a pour moi vis du
consentement, c'est une vente comme on
appelle dolosive parce qu'il y a eu des
manœuvres, des mensonges. Et donc
normalement dans la théorie générale des
obligations, lorsque vous signez un
contrat sous la pression de la
contrainte, menacz que vous êtes sous
l'emprise d'un chantage, d'un risque de
raquette, vous allez devant un tribunal
et vous dites "J'ai été floué, je fais
annuler la vente et retour en l'état
antérieur." C'est exactement ce que soit
l'entreprise Alstom pourrait faire
aujourd'hui, soit l'État français
pourrait faire.
OK ? L'État français le fait pas. Est-ce
que ça veut dire qu'on est tenu par les
couilles par les Américains ? Bah, les
Américains disposent de
de moyens importants. Ils l'ont fait,
ils ont fait cette opération à Siemens,
ils l'ont fait Tralstom à la BNP,
ils l'ont fait à Alcatel et à chaque
fois ça s'est traduit par des rachats.
Donc il va falloir maintenant prendre
des mesures de de résistance et de
protection. Donc les ventes,
pour ça que je suis favorable
aujourd'hui. Je serai le ministre de
l'économie, je saisirai euh le tribunal
compétent pour faire annuler la vente et
je vois pas comment il pourrait refuser
cette annulation. On reviendra en l'état
antérieur. Ça serait très désagréable
pour les actionnaires euh d'Alstom.
Ce serait très désagréable pour monsieur
Cron. Ce serait aussi très désagréable
pour les banquiers d'affaires, les
avocats qui ont travaillé sur cette
affaire parce que il risquerait de
d'avoir chaud à leur matricule. Mais euh
ce serait un très grand bien pour la
France.
Et derrière on subit les mesures de
rétorsion américaine. Ils nousent de
renseignement, il nous privue
une puissance de moyenne impuissance ?
Ben, si vous voulez mon avis, moi je
considère qu'on est devenu une colonie
numérique des États-Unis d'Amérique avec
les Gafas qui nous prennent nos données.
Euh donc, il y a aujourd'hui même des
Américains qui sont fondateurs de
Facebook par exemple qui proposent
démantellement des gafas. Il y a des
économistes européens qui ont proposé
aujourd'hui de couper en morceaux et en
rondelle les gafas. Donc, il faudra bien
il va y venir soit du côté américain,
soit du côté européen. Et j'ai pas
l'impression que la nouvelle Commission
européenne soit très orienté sur ces euh
sur ces choix importants. Pourquoi ?
Parce que on ne peut pas euh donner nos
propres nos propres ressources euh sans
contrepartie.
Là, il y a aucune contrepartie.
Regardez, aujourd'hui, toute l'économie
est dirigée par Google.
Vous prenez n'importe quelle entreprise,
un hôtel, un petit hôtel hein, un git,
une entreprise de n'importe quoi. Elle
est dirigée par Google. D'ailleurs,
combien vous disent ? Moi, mon patron
c'est Google. J'achète euh des mots clés
et en contrepartie j'ai des clients, on
achète nos clics.
Cette euh oppression de plus en plus
envahissante
va provoquer et va devoir provoquer une
forme de euh rébellion euh
politico-juridique
de l'Union européenne et il faudra la
penser, la réfléchir et l'organiser.
Qu'est-ce qui vous
vous croyez au Père Noël ?
Ah ben non, mais on aura pas le choix.
Pourquoi ? Parce que cette oppression
euh
économique, elle est appauvrissante.
Elle nous appauvrit.
Vous on s'adapte ou on s'adapte pas ? On
s'adapte au combat ou on s'adapte et on
combat.
Vous allez avoir des dirigeants
européens qui vont porter ça aux
prochaines élections.
Des des dirigeants européens plutôt
nationalistes un peu énervés.
protectionniste, des choses comme ça.
Non, je pense que dans le raisonnable,
la colère est entré. Moi par exemple, je
suis un homme raisonnable, proeuropéen
mais en colère,
mais extrêmement blessé par ce qui s'est
passé ces dernières années. Et je pense
que la colère de la population et même
d'une grande partie de la classe
dirigeante
de ces systèmes oppressif,
des empires qui rapprochent leur ombre,
la Chine, les États-Unis et qui vont
nous tailler en pièce va justifier que
nous changions complètement de méthode
et y compris que nous prenions des
mesures d'urgence conforme à l'intérêt
supérieur de notre pays.
Comme quoi ? Bah, par exemple, euh
lorsque vous avez
euh des prises de contrôle d'entreprise,
ben vous leur dites non.
Voilà. Non, quand par exemple cet acte
que vous aviez semblé qualifié très
agressif que je suggérais d'annuler la
vente d'Alstom, ça ferait du bien pour
l'avenir parce que ce serait une fume
une fusée rouge dans le ciel, un
avertissement sans frais pour tous ceux
qui voudraient s'aventurer en France à
prendre le contrôle de nos de nos du
travail de génération
accomplie sur notre territoire.
Le courage politique, ça s'apprend pas à
l'école,
ça s'apprend pas dans les banques
d'affaires. Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
est équipé ? Est-ce que vous pensez que
la population ne doit pas reprendre le
contrôle de sa démocratie ? Bah euh vous
préconisez un des des mesures un peu
plus musclées.
Euh
je pense que euh
les citoyens doivent faire
l'apprentissage de la reprise d'une
partie du contrôle
de la rébellion.
C'est du contrôle. Ils doivent contrôler
leurs dirigeants. Ça ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie. D'ailleurs, c'est ce que vous
faites vous comme journaliste. On n pas
journaliste.
Enfin, je sais pas ce que vous êtes,
mais vous êtes en tout cas engagé
dans le ce qui se passe dans le champ de
la des des affaires publiques. Vous ne
les délaissez pas à des spécialistes,
des techniciens, des experts. Vous
considérez qu'elle vous appartient. Par
exemple, l'affaire du référendum de
l'aéroport de Paris. Un sujet très
intéressant.
Euh j'ai été à une conférence à l'école
nationale normale supérieur l'école
normale supérieure pas l'école national
administration non l'école normale
supérieure qui forme la fine fleur de
notre de notre intelligencia et c'était
très intéressant parce qu'on a eu un
débat avec des gens qui étaient pour la
privatisation des gens qui étaient
contre la privatisation je suis moi-même
défavorable à cette privatisation
pourquoi parce que il y a 36 aéroports
dans le monde qui ont déjà été
privatisés et on sait comment ça s'est
produit, ça s'est terminé. Quand vous
donnez un monopole public à une
entreprise privée, vous vous retrouvez
avec des remontées de prix puisque on
est en situation de monopole et qu'on
peut abuser de la clientèle. Et la
clientèle, c'est pas les duty free shop,
ça n'a aucun rapport. Bon, ça ça
concerne même pas je pense 30 % du
chiffre d'affaires, c'est les redevants
sur les compagnies aériennes. Donc vous
donnez aéroport de Paris à une
entreprise privée, quelle qu'elle soit,
quelle qu'elle soit, française,
chinoise, quel qu'elle soit, le droit de
fixer les prix, ce qui est toujours le
cas dans les conventions qui sont
signées, les contrats de concession
surtout pour 70 ans. Pensez bien que le
prix est libre parce que sur 70 ans,
s'ils peuvent pas choisir le prix, je il
y en a pas un qui candidatera pour
l'obtenir. Et bien, on sait que tous les
prix vont remonter et que vous allez
avoir Airfance en très grande
difficulté. Voilà ce qui va se passer.
Et c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
dans les 36 aéroports qui ont été
privatisés dans le monde. Tous les prix
ont remonté et vous avez eu euh des
chute de euh
de rentabilité pour toutes les
compagnies euh qui jouaient à domicile.
Courage politique.
Alors votre question, elle consiste en
quoi ? Vous voulez me faire dire quoi
exactement ?
Alors vous faire dire quoi ? Je ne sais
pas. On trouve que le courage en
politique c'est un petit peu un effet de
manche.
Il y a plus beaucoup de de gens
courageux, je vais dire comme vous, pour
aller monter au créneau et puis offrir
sa tête en sortant de son ministère
libre comme un homme libre. Comment ça
se fait qu'une are intelligent est
devenue
couarde ?
Écoutez, j'ai pas l'impression que ce
soit un trait de notre époque. Euh bon,
les gens sont tous fascinés par le
pouvoir. Euh la question c'est le prix
qu'on prêt on est prêt à payer.
Voilà.
Est-ce que euh
on paye le prix euh de recommencer sa
vie à zéro quand tout s'arrête ?
Bah moi, je suis prêt à le faire parce
que parce que je suis comme ça. Je sais
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs. Peut-être que
c'est un trait de caractère qui m'est
défavorable. Mais en tout cas euh tout
le monde n'est pas prêt à ça. On peut
pas demander à ce que tout le monde soit
vertueux et soit des sains. En revanche,
on peut exiger
d'un système politique qui est des
cordes de rappel
que les citoyens puissent intervenir.
C'est pour ça que je voulais vous dire
que le référendum d'initiative partagée
qui a été mis en branle par des
parlementaires, c'est l'occasion pour
les citoyens de s'en emparer et donc
d'aller signer. Moi, j'ai signé d'aller
signer sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur et je lance un appel, allez
l'intérieur. Que vous soyez pour ou
contre, le débat aura lieu, il sera
public à la télévision avec du pour du
contre. Mais signé pour avoir le droit
de choisir parce qu'on a déjà eu un un
exemple, c'est l'aéroport de Toulouse.
Il était privatisé entre les mains de
Chinois qui ont pompé la trésorerie euh
dont les dirigeants étaient plus ou
moins en fuite. Et on a expliqué que
c'était pas une privatisation parce
qu'on gardait 51 % euh du capital, ce
qui était une supercherie en vérité
parce qu'il y avait un pack
d'actionnaire qui disait le contraire de
ce que euh le ministre à l'époque avait
déclaré.
Quand François Hollande apprend par les
révélations d'Edward Snowdon qu'il était
écouté par la NSA.
Euh comment comment vous expliquez le
fait que on nit pas réexpédié
Manu Militari quelques diplomates
américain pour leur expliquer qu'on fait
passer à la maison ? Bah, il y a eu 72
millions de selon les révélations
d'Edouward Snowden, ancien cadre de la
NSA, 72 millions de conversations qui
ont été
interceptées par la NSA dans un lapse de
temps de 6 ou 7 mois en France qui
concernait pas seulement les autorités
politiques, qui concernait les
entreprises, concernaient les
particuliers, 72 millions SMS, mail,
interception de conversation
téléphonique.
Euh je rappelle que quand monsieur
Pierucci a été menoté et emmené devant
le procureur Amathan, euh on lui a dit
"Nous avons euh"
si mes souvenirs sont bons, d'après ce
qu'il a déclaré lui-même euh dans son
livre, nous avons 300000 mails
sur l'entreprise Alstom.
La NSA est un outil d'écoute de
renseignement illégal contre des
nations, contre des États, contre des
peuples
qui a pour qui sert les objectifs de la
déstabilisation d'entreprise au fin de
rachat et de capture. Voilà ce qui s'est
passé, la preuve par la par le document.
Donc quand il y a eu ces 72 millions
de de
de fuite d'interception,
la France est rangée
non pas du côté de Snowden, mais du côté
des États-Unis d'Amérique.
Il y a même eu un incident, le président
péruvien
qui avait son avion officiel qui
décollait de Moscou en Russie où Snowden
était avait demandé l'asile politique
était confiné dans une pièce sans douche
et sans lumière pendant plusieurs mois.
Les Américains ont soupçonné le
président péruvien d'avoir emmené dans
sa soute à bagage le pauvre Snowen pour
lui l'emmener dans son pays, lui
accorder l'asile politique à son tour
après la Russie. Quelque chose comme ça.
De façon nocturne,
les États-Unis ont demandé lorsque le
survol de l'Europe a commencé par
l'avion du président péruvien la
fermeture des frontières. Espagne
accordé, Italie accordé, Angleterre
accordée, Allemagne refusé, France
accordée.
Donc le l'avion s'est posé à Vienne.
Les inspecteurs vienénois ont fait un
tour. On n'ont rien trouvé évidemment.
Ça a fait un incident diplomatique. La
France a été conspuée dans toutes les
ambassades d'Amérique latine puisque les
citoyens sud-américain prenaient
finalement le parti du
président péruvien dont l'avion avait
été injustement arraisonné
et la France a été le drapeau français a
été brûlé devant plusieurs ambassades
sud-américaines.
Et ensuite, il y a eu le voyage à
Washington quelques mois plus tard
auquel j'ai participé.
Lors de la conférence de presse commune
entre le président François Hollande et
le président Barack Obama, il y a eu
trois phrases sur l'affaire Snowden.
On en a parlé, on a traité le problème
et nous sommes maintenant d'accord.
Il n'y a pas eu de questions parce qu'il
n'y avait que six questions qui ont été
posées. Il y en a une qui était sur les
six questions et l'affaire en est restée
là. Pourquoi nous en sommes là ? parce
que la France et les États-Unis ont une
tradition d'imbation
extrêmement,
j'allais dire forte.
Je me souviendrai toujours quand j'ai
appelé le directeur des renseignements
extérieurs,
je lui ai dit "Nous sommes écoutés dans
l'affaire Alstom et on utilise quand
j'ai découvert le potoros Pierucci,
j'étais au gouvernement.
Nous sommes écoutés, on utilise les
informations d'Alstom pour amener le
département de justice à exercer un
chantage sur les dirigeants actuels
d'Alstom. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous
aider ? Il a dit "Nous n'écoutons pas
les Américains, c'est un accord entre
nous
parce que ce sont nos alliés." Très
bien. Donc nous on est écouté mais on
refuse de le faire dans le sens inverse.
Donc il est évident que la dissymétrie
euh des relations ne peut pas durer et
qu'un moment ou un autre, il va falloir
qu'on reprenne nos droits. Par exemple,
je voudrais vous donner un autre
exemple. Il y a un programme qui
s'appelle ITAR. C'est un programme très
important qui permet selon un accord de
sécurisation des pièces critiques de
tous les équipements militaires ou
civils aux États-Unis sur une liste qui
concerne 27000 pièces aux États-Unis
d'empêcher
tout appareil, un avion de chasse, un
bâtiment militaire, que sais-je encore,
qui contiendrait une pièce ITAR de
l'exporter vers une destination qu'il
jugerait indésirable.
Donc nous sommes nous avons accepté
nous-mêmes. C'est c'est ce que la
Boesséie avait théorisé sous la forme de
la servitude volontaire. Donc il va
falloir, ça fait partie du grand
programme de j'allais dire liberté dont
nous avons besoin en France. il va
falloir se sortir de ce type de euh
cilité
parce que nous ne pouvons pas
Mais c'est d'accord mais ce sont 50 ans
de relation atlantiste euh d'intrication
au sein de l'OTAN du commandement
intégré comme vous le savez euh où nous
jouons quelques utilités euh et de
suivisme vis-à-vis des intérêts
américains. cette question. Si
d'ailleurs on pose la question
géostratégique, comment allons-nous
faire dans la bataille qui se prépare
entre la Chine et l'Amérique ? Notre
intérêt à nous, c'est de faire ce que le
général de Gaulle avait fait au moment
de la guerre froide entre les deux
empires soviétiques et américains, les
cuidistance.
Donc nous devons construire cette
relation nouvelle. Je vois pas pourquoi
on ne pourrait pas le faire. On l'a déjà
fait dans l'histoire.
On va revenir sur l'afféréal Stom. Quand
vous voyez le secrétaire général de
l'Élysée commander une étude en 2012 sur
la faisabilité de d'Alstom
dans le dos de son ministre,
ça vous évoque quoi ? C'est c'est on se
renseigne,
on
découvert après la que l'Assemblée
nationale a créé une commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur les
circonstances dans lesquelles
Alstom a été vendu à General Electric.
Euh cette étude que je ne connaissais
pas. Donc je l'ai découverte en 2000, ça
devait être 18 4 ans après. Je la
connaissais pas, je l'avais pas lu. Bon
et d'ailleurs, j'ai rechercher parmi mes
collaborateurs qui l'avait lu et en fait
je crois que personne ne l'avait
vraiment lu. Il n'y avait attaché de
l'importance puisque c'était une
commande qui avait été présentée comme
venant des services. Mais nous les
services ne commandent pas. Les services
monsieur, ce sont les services qui sont
sous mon autorité. Donc c'était l'agence
de participation de l'État
300000 €.
Oui, c'est ça. Ils ont un budget pour
commander toutes sortes d'études dans le
cadre de leur mandat. Moi j'avais fait
faire une étude auprès de Rolland Berger
sur les conséquences d'une fusion avec
tel autre concurrent qui était arrivé en
février 2014. Je l'avais présenté à Cron
qui avait dit "Arrêtez de m'envoyer vos
stagiaires à Chaussé poser des questions
sur notre stratégie." pendant que
lui-même était en train de vendre Alstom
aux Américains. Euh ça c'est un acte de
déloyauté et de trahison.
Cron vous a menacé non d'un plan social
à 5000 personnes.
Ah ben évidemment quand on est entré
dans le dans le moment de vérité, je
l'ai fait convoquer des chefs à la
sortie de son avion pour lui demander de
quoi il s'agissait. On vend pas une
entreprise qui vide la commande
publique,
qui
a une relation stratégique avec notre
indépendance militaire et stratégique
et une entreprise qu'on a nationalisé
en 2003, c'est le président Sarkozy qui
avait fait ça pour sauver. On ne la vend
pas le vendredi soir à gén électrique
avec mise devant le fait accompli pour
le dimanche soir. C'est ce qu'il a il a
fait monsieur Cron. Pour moi, c'est une
trahison.
Et monsieur Cron, si j'étais le
président de la République aujourd'hui,
je lui retirais sa légion d'honneur car
c'est une trahison de la France de sa
part. C'est quand même un
polytechnicien, il a défilé
sur les Champs-Élysées lorsqu'il était
jeune. Est-ce qu'il a oublié ce qu'il
doit à la France ?
C'était un homme qui était en situation
de pression judiciaire. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait quand on est un patriote
sincère ?
et qu'on est dans cette situation. On
est accusé de corruption par le plus
grand état du monde. On est sûr de pas
pouvoir s'en sortir. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? Et bien, on remet son mandat à
son gouvernement. On dit "Je suis en
situation de vulnérabilité, je peux pas
continuer." Et on prend les mesures de
protection de l'intérêt de la France. Et
en contrepartie, nous on aurait protégé
Cron. Euh monsieur Perrocci nous dit que
les les pots de vin étaient déclarés
jusqu'en 2000 à Ber euh que c'était
d'ailleurs défiscalisé.
Euh euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
là-dessus ?
Ben que le monde entier euh les Chinois
euh les Chinois par exemple ont corrompu
toute l'Afrique. C'est comme ça qu'ils
ont pris des parts de marché. La France
aussi a corrompu. Afrique
mais mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
euh aujourd'hui il y a les traités, la
convention de l'OCDE qui empêche la
corruption d'agents étrangers et puis il
y a la pratique
et la pratique, regardez ce qui s'est
passé au Departement of Justice et à
presque aucune entreprise américaine
n'était poursuivie pour corruption. Donc
la NSA qui écoute si bien le reste du
monde pourrait aussi écouter les
pratiques concurrentes de corruption des
grandes entreprises américaines. Ne le
fait pas. C'est peut-être à nous de le
faire. Si si je vous
si je vous dis pacte de corruption,
si je vous dis 600 millions d'euros
d'honoraires versés à la suite d'Alston,
on a arrosé tout le monde. Tout le monde
se tient par
Bah écoutez, bon officiellement ce sont
des avocats et des euh banquiers qui ont
mené les opérations.
Bon voilà, tout Paris avait été
loué par Général électrique, les agences
de communication, les banqu les
banquiers d'affaires et les avocats, les
grands cabinets avocats. Très bien.
Souvent américains. Très bien. Bah il y
a une justice, la justice enquête. On
verra bien ce qu'elle découvrira.
Le parquet national financier est saisi.
Il s'est saisi.
H
qui a mis le procureur du parquet à la
tête du parquet national financier ?
Pardon ? Qui qui a qui a qui a nommé le
procureur du parquet national financier
? Qui qui a nommé le magistrat ?
Bah là, il est vacant le poste hein. Il
est vacant comme vous le savez. Donc
c'est madame le garde des sauts qui va
nommer.
Mais il faut le savoir c'est tout.
Voilà. Parlons un peu d'Europe. Est-ce
que l'Europe nous protège ? Est-ce que
l'Europe a des chevaux de trois qui
foutent la France dans la merde ? Est-ce
que vous pouvez préciser votre question
? En terme en ter en terme d'économie,
est-ce que l'Europe protège la France ?
Bah l'Europe déjà protège pas l'Europe
et les Européens.
Vous voulez que je sois vraiment
provoquant ?
Non non parce que j'ai compris votre
question maintenant.
Euh mais c'est une tout à fait
pertinente. Euh
les Américains
et les Chinois se livre une guerre sans
merci en ce moment sur le plan
commercial.
Les Européens eux n'arrivent pas à
prendre de décision sur ce qu'on appelle
l'antidumping.
Qu'est-ce que le dumping ? Par exemple,
je prends un exemple tout simple, le
magnésium. On a besoin de magnésium pour
parce que c'est un métal qui est assez
précieux, rare. On avait des carrières
de magnésium en France, des usines de
transformation de magnésium. La Chine
décide de prendre le marché du
magnésium. Il le planifie, l'organise,
il casse les prix, ils vendent à perte
dans le monde entier. Nos usines ferment
parce qu'elles peuvent pas survivre,
c'est pas compétitif.
On perd les emplois, les savoir-fair,
les ressources naturelles et après on
achète le magnésium à qui ? aux Chinois
et il remontent les prix. Ils ont fait
ça dans tous les secteurs de la
métallurgie, ils l'ont fait dans
l'acier, les aciers spéciaux et cetera.
Nous n'avons plus nous la capacité
depuis le traité de Rome 1957 de prendre
des mesures de protection d'intérêt
national. Donc nous avons délégué à
l'Union européenne le soin de nous
protéger. Que fait l'Union européenne ?
Elle ne prend aucune mesure antidumping.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'il y a pas de
majorité dans l'Union européenne pour se
protéger contre le dumping notamment
chinois. Mais le dumping américain, ce
serait la même chose. Donc on met des
mesures généralement pour trouver des
majorités au sein des conseils. Des
mesures qui sont des demi-mesures. Par
exemple, on met 12 % de taxe quand les
Américains mettent 250 %. Voilà, on
n'arrive pas à avoir une Europe qui se
rassemble autour de ses intérêts parce
que l'Europe est divisée. Vous avez les
Allemands qui n'ont que Attendez, je
vous explique pourquoi. Parce que c'est
c'est pas seulement l'Europe l'Europe.
Dans l'Europe, il y a des Européens et
des dirigeants européens. C'est
intéressant de savoir qui vote quoi.
Alors, en gros, les pays du sud, les
pays francophones sont avec nous. Bon,
les pays du nord sont avec l'Allemagne
et l'Angleterre souvent avec
l'Allemagne. Elle ne l'est plus mais
l'Irlande jouer parfaitement ce jeulà.
Et l'Allemagne, elle n'a qu'une seule
obsession, c'est vendre ses automobiles
en Chine. Donc elle ne veut prendre
aucune mesure contre la Chine. Donc il
n'y a pas de coupe franco-allemand
d'intérêt communéens.
Est-ce que l'Europe est est gangrenée,
vérôée
par des intérêts de puissance étrangère
? L'Europe est divisée, c'est-à-dire que
vous avez des pays qui préfèrent jouer
une politique de cavalier seul s'en
sortir seul vis-à-vis de la Chine, s'
sortir seul vis-à-vis des Américains et
sont incapables de prendre en quelque
sorte leur responsabilité d'Européens.
Alors, vous dites que que la France est
capable de dire non. LUL a justement
démontré, demandé de dire non au CTA
et et bah la France a voté le CTA.
C'était parce que on pouvait pas dire
oui ou on pouvait pas dire non.
Bah écoutez, j'ai envie de vous dire
faut demander aux parlementaires qui
l'ont voté notamment de la majorité
puisquils ont une majorité. Donc Nicolas
Hulot qui était il y a peu encore au
gouvernement a appelé à voter non les
députés de la majorité
qui ne l'ont pas écouté. Donc moi,
qu'est-ce que je chaque parlementaire a
une parcelle de responsabilité.
Euh il a 1577e
de responsabilité dans le vote de ce
type d'accord qui aura de grandes
conséquences parce que dans ce type
d'accord, vous avez des clauses qui
permettent à des multinationales de
faire condamner les États quand elles
changent leur législation
environnementale.
C'est pas pour rien que monsieur Nicolas
Hullot a dit ça et d'ailleurs, je
soutiens sa position
comme entrepreneur, comme citoyen.
Je soutiens sa position.
Pardon ? le on va on va reprendre nos
nos questions autour de du verro de
Bery. C'est quoi le verreau de Bery ?
Ben, il existe au ministère du budget
une procédure
qui fait que lorsque une fraude est
constatée sur le plan fiscal, fraude, ça
veut dire c'est la procédure pénale,
criminelle, hein.
Il faut d'abord obtenir l'autorisation
de l'administration fiscale qui va
valider l'existence de la fraude
pour euh engager les poursuites.
Exemple, on découvre un fichier de 3000
exilés fiscaux en Suisse qui ont
dissimulé des avoirs sans les déclarer.
Vous avez le droit d'avoir en France,
vous avez le droit d'avoir des avoirs à
l'étranger à condition que vous les
déclariez dans votre déclaration
d'impôts et donc fiscalisé. Si vous les
déclarez pas, c'est pénal, c'est de la
fraute. C'est monsieur Causac par
exemple, un exemple au hasard. Bien. Euh
quand on découvre 3000 personnes,
vous pouvez décider soit de poursuivre
3000 personnes au pénal, soit vous dites
"Ben, on va faire une cellule de
dégrisement." C'est-à-dire euh voilà,
vous êtes allé un peu loin ou c'était
votre papa qui avait planqué cet argent
il y a 30 ans, c'est un héritage, vous
n'y êtes pour rien, d'accord ? et on
trouve un accord, vous rapatriez les
avoirs, vous payez un forfait, l'affaire
est terminée. Ça ça va pour quand il y a
200000 € qui sont cachés depuis 70 ans
dans un compte suisse. Ça peut
s'accepter. Mais quand il s'agit de
millions, de centaines de millions, là
on a besoin de transparence. Donc le
verrou de Bercy euh pour moi a eu un
effet pervers, c'est qu'il a empêché
finalement des procédure pénale contre
des gens qui finalement n'avaient pas
été loyal à leur pays, qui profitent de
leur pays sans en payer la contrepartie,
c'est-à-dire l'impôt.
Si je vous dis Stéphanie Gibau, les
lanceurs d'alerte, l'affaire HSBC. Ah
bah la chef HSBC, je la connais bien.
Oui, c'était monsieur Falciani qui était
un des informaticiens à Genève qui a
fort heureusement apporter
toutes les informations sur la table de
la République. D'ailleurs, je les y aid.
Je les ai je les ai aidé à l'époque,
j'étais pas au gouvernement, j'étais
dans l'opposition et nous avons
participé, c'est vrai, à ce travail.
Est-ce que Est-ce que la loi Sapin 2
protège correctement les les lanceurs
d'alerte ?
Pas suffisamment à mes yeux.
D'ailleurs, il y a eu un grand progrès
qui a été fait sur le sujet mais qui
mériterait d'être conforté. Une question
internet. Est-ce que l'affaire Dominique
Stroskan a été instrumentalisée par les
US ?
Euh, je ne peux pas répondre à ces
questions. Je ne sais pas.
Je ne sais pas
pour le neutraliser
un peu plus tard. Non,
je ne sais pas.
D'accord. On va prendre une autre
question. Euh l'armée qui se fait qui se
fait coiffer par la NSA tout le temps.
Euh euh est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils
vont devenir un petit peu nerveux et
bypasser le le la chaîne de commandement
? Parce que la chaîne de commandement ne
les protège plus. En gros, est-ce qu'on
va on va avoir des militaires un petit
peu rêvants d'un coup d'état ?
Je ne vois pas de quoi vous parlez. Ce
que euh ce qui m'inquiéterait, c'est que
euh on se retrouve en France
euh avec militaire vous fait peur
avec Non, je le désapprouve et le
combattrait. La France est une
République.
On a coupé la tête d'un roi pour établir
la démocratie. non pas qu'une faction
puisse s'emparer du pouvoir. Donc en ce
qui me concerne euh lorsque il y a eu le
coup d'état le PCH des généraux, c'était
en à Alger en 1961 si mes souvenirs sont
bons, je me souviens que mon père était
avait répondu à l'appel de Michel Debré,
ministre de l'intérieur je crois, ou
premier ministre, qui avait dit "Venez
euh rejoignez-nous pour défendre la
République. Donc moi, je ferai comme mon
père." Vous voyez, je suis contre les
prises de pouvoir par la force. Je suis
pour l'expression démocratique. Je suis
d'ailleurs le l'auteur d'un projet de 6e
République que j'ai rédigé il y a
presque 10 ans maintenant
et qui proposait d'améliorer les
processus démocratiques, augmenter la
transparence, permettre finalement à ce
que les intérêts de la nation soient
mieux préservés.
Je crois qu'on peut faire beaucoup de
progrès aujourd'hui
dans les mécanismes démocratiques.
Le RIC, ça vous parle ?
Le
référendum d'initiative citoyennes ?
Oui, je je suis favorable au RC.
D'ailleurs, je l'avais proposé lorsque
j'étais parlementaire. Je n'avais pas
obtenu de majorité dans mon groupe à
l'époque. Je l'ai proposé dans la 6e
République a RC
parce qu'on en a besoin. On a besoin de
temps en temps que les citoyens
reprennent le contrôle. Il s'agit pas de
faire comme les Suisses, de voter tous
les dimanches. Tous les dimanches, il y
a un référendum en Suisse. Mais je peux
vous dire que dans des grandes question
qui se pose, vous en avez posé un
certain nombre là aujourd'hui, dans les
questions locales, la commune, le
département, ça ferait du bien.
Finalement, les élus peuvent partager le
pouvoir. Quel est le problème ? Ils sont
confortés. D'ailleurs, l'élu qu''est-il
un délégataire de la souveraineté
temporaire normalement. Donc moi je
trouve que ça ferait du bien, ça
fortifierait la démocratie dans notre
pays et l'esprit public comme on dit. Si
si on parle un peu gilets jaunes, est-ce
que vous pensez que la crise des gilets
jaunes se gère correctement en terme de
maintien de l'ordre ?
Bah pour moi euh si je voudrais revenir
sur les causes de l'apparition de la du
mouvement des Gilos si vous me le
permettez. Avec plaisir.
Euh, il y a un
cabinet de conseil américain qui n'est
pas une officine mélanchonniste, loin de
là, qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle euh Mckinz.
Ah, Mckinz. qui a fait une étude sur
l'évolution de la richesse dans les pays
de l'OCDE dans la dernière décennie. Ils
ont observé que 72 % des ménages de
l'OCDE, donc la France est dedans, avait
vu leur pouvoir d'achat
se réduire ou stagner,
c'est-à-dire 580 millions de personnes
en 10 ans. 580 millions de personnes
dans la décennie précédente,
c'est-à-dire avant 2008, c'était
seulement 10 millions de personnes qui
avaient vu leur pouvoir d'achat, le
pouvoir le pouvoir de vivre se réduire
ou stagner. Donc vous avez 72 % des
ménages qui se sont appauvrent
de s'écouler. Et pendant ce tempsl
l'économie a continué à créer de la
richesse.
Que s'est-il passé ? 82 % de cette
richesse est allé se concentrer sur 1 %
des patrimoines et des individus.
Donc là, vous avez les causes de la
révolte. Alors, j'ai pour familiarité de
dire que lorsque j'ai quitté le
gouvernement, c'était sur un désaccord
sur la préparation du budget. Je voulais
qu'on mette fin à l'austérité budgétaire
qui a fait payer finalement les ménages
et les familles en France le prix de la
crise, ce qui continue d'ailleurs. Et le
désaccord, le premier ministre de
l'époque, monsieur Valz, il dit, on ne
quitte pas le gouvernement pour 15
milliards. Puisque le désaccord, c'était
15 milliards à redistribuer au ménage
que eux ne voulaient pas redonner. Je
leur dit, c'est pas possible.
Et finalement, les gilets jaunes ont
manifesté pour presque obtenir 15
milliards à peu près, grosso modo. Quand
on regarde ce qui s'est produit, ce que
le président de la République Macron a
lâché, les mesures qui s'en sont
suivies, c'est environ ce que nombre
d'entre nous déjà dénonçait comme devant
revenir dans la poche des ménages pour
relancer l'activité économique dans
notre pays et soulager les familles du
poids de la crise. Alors après, est-ce
qu'une crise comme ça se règle par des
questions de maintien de l'or ? Je crois
pas.
Je crois pas. Il y a pas d'isse.
D'ailleurs, c'est une escalade. Pour les
forces de l'ordre, c'est extrêmement dur
pour les personnes blessées qui ont été
touchées et qui ont le droit de
manifester, excusez-moi, on a le droit
de manifester une garantie
constitutionnelle. Est-elle
est-elle encore préservée ? Ce sont des
questions qu'on a le droit de se poser.
Il y a des associations qui défendent
les libertés publiques qui les posent.
Donc on est en droit quand même de se
poser toutes ces questions euh
aujourd'hui.
La presse à l'heure actuelle, est-ce que
euh quand on voit Cédrico, secrétaire
d'État, vouloir faire un conseil
supérieur du journalisme, est-ce que ça
vous interpelle, ça vous inquiète ?
Ben écoutez, nous avons une loi qui
protège la presse de 1881 mais qui
protège la liberté d'expression en
général.
Vous avez le droit
de tout dire, sauf de porter à
l'honneur, à la considération,
à l'exception
de la circonstance où vous dites la
vérité. Donc la vérité est protégée dans
le droit de la presse.
Faut-il encore pouvoir le prouver ?
C'est toute la question. Mais si vous
apportez la preuve de ce que vous dites,
vous êtes protégé par la loi sur la
presse. Bon, c'est un équilibre qui a
été construit dans la grande période de
des bâtisseurs de la 3e République.
C'est un équilibre subtil qui a été,
j'allais dire affiné, conforté au fil
des siècles. Maintenant, on peut parler
de siècle. Donc, je désapprouve toute
idée qui consistera à la remettre en
question. C'est comme la loi de 1901 sur
les associations, c'est comme la loi de
1905 sur la laïcité. Ce sont des lois
fondatrices de la République et nous
avons besoin de piliers dans la période
actuelle, dans ces temps de trouble et
de violence.
La concentration de la presse par des
oligarques
en France, on peut faire quelque chose,
on peut pas faire quelque chose, c'est
un relais de propagande. C'est quoi ?
Bah vous avez un vous avez un problème,
c'est que comme la presse est en
décitude et qu'elle ne peut plus gagner
sa vie, vous avez des investisseurs
forcément riches qui ont déjà fait leur
fortune et non pas des entrepreneurs qui
peuvent espérer gagner leur vie en euh
construisant des journaux euh qui
prennent le contrôle de journaux. Donc
là, vous avez le sujet de la protection
de la liberté de conscience des
journalistes. Il existe des mesures de
protection
par des statuts des rédactions.
Normalement, l'actionnariat doit être
distingué et doit être distingué
de la direction, j'allais dire
intellectuelle ou
euh
idéologique du journal. Normalement, il
devrait y avoir ces distinctions. C'est
pas très compliqué de l'imposer. Le
législateur pourrait le faire. Il y a
déjà eu des tentatives dans le passé. On
peut même faire une loi où tout le monde
sera d'accord.
On peut le faire mais il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire. Voyez,
on va revenir un peu sur la
géopolitique.
La Chine, on peut leur faire confiance
ou pas ?
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire ? Vous
pouvez préciser votre question.
Est-ce qu'un de Est-ce qu'un deal avec
la Chine est respecté ?
Écoutez, vous posez la question de façon
euh je dirais euh euh
pour moi
c'est difficile de répondre à votre
question.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà assisté à des
deales avec des Chinois ?
Euh oui, bien sûr,
c'est compliqué. Mais avec les anglais
aussi, vous savez, c'est difficile, je
vais vous le dire. Euh d'ailleurs avec
toute culture différente de la nôtre,
c'est toujours difficile. Bon,
dans la négociation,
oui, puis même dans la dans l'exécution
aussi, c'est compliqué. Non, ce que je
voudrais dire, c'est que euh qu'est-ce
que une Europe qui est en train de se
fracturer ?
Ce que je ne souhaite pas.
Je suis favorable à une force
européenne, économique
et politique.
Est-ce qu'on fait le frexite ?
Bah non. Non, d'ailleurs, on avait fait
chiffrer ce que donnerait le Frexit. Le
Frexit, ça nous coûterait extrêmement
cher.
Moins 12 une paire de 12 points de PIB.
D'ailleurs, pour ça que il y a peu de
gens qui le qui s'aventurent à le
demander. Donc, soyons Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'on a la monnaie unique. Les anglais
eux n'ont pas de monnaie unique, ils
avaient la liv sterling. Donc, je pense
que nous pouvons parfaitement être
lucide là-dessus. En revanche, l'Union
européenne ne peut pas continuer à
fonctionner comme elle fonctionne. Ça,
c'est pas possible. Et donc comment dans
une Europe qui se fracture, comment
fait-on avec des États-Unis qui se
comportent de façon de plus en plus
impérialiste
et des Chinois qui se comportent de
façon de plus en plus impérialiste ?
Est-ce qu'on tend
Quelle est notre stratégie ?
Est-ce qu'on tend la main à la Russie ?
Bah déjà euh la question c'est pas la
question russe, c'est d'abord la
question européenne. Donc on a besoin
urgent de refonder l'Union européenne et
sur des bases beaucoup plus simples où
les États-nations peuvent retrouver leur
oxygène.
On disait ça la il y a il y a 20 ans, on
disait la même chose, refonder l'Europe
machin.
J'ai pas dit tout à fait ça. J'ai dit où
les États-ntations retrouvent leur
place. Euh qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit ? On
nous dit toujours il faut aller vers
plus d'Europe mais on voit bien qu'à
chaque fois qu'on approfondit l'Union
européenne, on se paralyse tous.
L'Europe est une immense paralytique à
28 pays qui n'a pas de majorité. Vous
avez déjà essayé de mettre 28 personnes
dans une pièce pour prendre des
décisions dans une famille sur un
héritage par exemple ou une copropriété.
Bah vous n'avez jamais de majorité, vous
n'y arrivez pas. Donc qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire ? Bah il faut trouver
d'autres modes de décision et surtout
peut-être
imaginer que les États-nations puissent
reprendre le droit de défendre leurs
intérêts lorsqu'ils sont en difficulté.
Point important. Il ne s'agit pas parce
que l'Union européenne a privé les
États-nations de pouvoir d'agir et n'a
pas constitué au plan européen des
pouvoirs supranationaux qui permettaient
de résoudre les problèmes. Le climat,
le problème migratoire, la question de
la croissance et de l'austérité,
la question énergétique, tout ça n'a pas
été traité par l'Union européenne et on
a empêché les États-nations de le faire.
Bon, donc un retour aux États-ntions me
paraît absolument souhaitable dans un
cadre européen où on peut juste déplacer
le curseur des pouvoirs attribués aux
États sans remettre en cause un édifice
collectif et commun. C'est ma position.
Voilà. Alors après, dans ce monde qui se
fracture, quels sont nos alliés dans le
monde ?
L'Inde, la Russie et les Africains.
Les États-Unis, c'est plus du tout nos
alliés maintenant. Ben, les États-Unis
euh sont des alliés euh agressifs qui
portent atteinte à nos intérêts. On a
des preuves, je crois, on a des faits,
on en a assez parlé aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils ont mis un
doigt dans l'affaire Alst parce que
Alstom se rapprochait trop des Chinois
et des Russes ?
Non, je crois pas. Je crois qu'il y a
une espèce de Non, je crois pas. D'abord
le rapprochement avec les Chinois et les
Russes était pour moi euh restait pour
l'instant très anecdotique. Voilà. Euh
moi je considère que par exemple on a
dans l'automobile, on a une alliance
avec les Japonais qu'il faut défendre,
Renault Nissan qu'il faut défendre.
Les est fondamental
Carlos Gun, il est il est dans un
Je je j'enlève les personnes, vous me le
permettrez. Euh restons sur la sur le le
l'alliance. L'alliance Renault Nissan a
été extraordinaire. On a fait le numéro
1 mondial dans l'automobile. Donc quand
on nous dit on va faire une alliance
avec Fiat Chrisler, excusez-moi, on a
déjà le numéro 1 mondial euh en terme de
dire devant Volkswagen.
Voilà, parce que c'est euh Renault,
Nissan, Mitsubishi, Aftovaz, donc Lada,
il y a les Russes dedans. Donc c'est les
Japonais, des Russes euh
et un peu un peu chinois d'ailleurs.
Donc nous avons là, je crois, des
éléments de réflexion que nous devons
avoir dans un monde qui devient
périlleux, dangereux, où les empires se
dressent et où nos ressources
européennes se fragilisent.
On va parler d'écologie.
Vous dites que le l'écologie est
incompatible avec la globalisation.
Quand on fait des grands groupes comme
ça, transcontinentaux, est-ce que c'est
compatible ou pas ? Peut-être pas. Quand
il y a une gamine de 16 ans qui vient
faire la leçon à des parlementaires,
Greta Tunberg, c'est normal, c'est pas
normal ? Est-ce que écologiquement
parlant, c'est pas un peu du wishful
sinking auprès de notre gouvernement et
des différents gouvernements ? Puisque
on narrive pas encore à gagner des
points de PIB avec l'écologie.
Est-ce que vous pensez réellement que
nos États vont prendre à bras le corps
les questions écologiques ?
B
et est-ce qu' il laisse pas parler la
petite de 16 ans pour se donner bonne
conscience pour faire une petite
opération de communication comme
Non mais ça c'est des questions
trop politiques pour moi. Vous me
permettrez ? Je vais pas entrer dans ce
débat là. Oh là là.
En revanche, je vais vous répondre sur
la question de l'écologie.
L'écologie n'a de sens que si elle se
marie avec l'économie. Vou pas vous
voulez pas rentrer un petit peu dans le
game là politiquement parlant vous avez
quand même une grande expéri
vous avez une grande expérience écoute
fait votre boulot
écoutez-moi vous mett vous mettes très
sympathique mais vous
vous mettes sympathique aussi mais vous
avez un un devoir envers des Français
un devoir
ouais qui est comme vous avez bien fait
votre boulot il faut continuer
d'abord je vous remercie de dire j'ai
bien fait mon boulot mais pour moi
surstom surstom
pour moi c'est juste normal quand vous
êtes quand c'est juste normal il en a
pas à recevoir. avoir des compliments,
je les accepte volontiers et vous en
remercie.
Mais pour moi, c'est juste
je suis content d'avoir payé mes impôts
pour payer votre salaire.
Merci monsieur. C'est très gentil. Je
sais pas qui vous êtes mais vous m'êtes
sympathique. Mais je vais vous dire une
chose. Quand vous avez des questions
écologiques aussi lourdes qui commencent
à se poser,
euh vous voyez bien que l'écologie, elle
doit se marier avec
la société, avec l'économie, sinon ça
marche pas. l'écologie,
l'économie, l'écologie, ça peut pas être
des décisions qui tombent en haut avec
des punitions pour tout le monde. Ça ne
peut être que des changements assumés et
organisés où la charge est répartie
entre tous et de façon la plus juste
possible.
Donc au lieu de faire payer des taxes
sur l'essence des pauvres gens qui sont
obligés d'utiliser leur voiture pour
aller travailler, d'ailleurs qui ont pas
les moyens de la changer parce que
généralement la fin du mois un peu
juste. Vous voyez de quoi je parle ?
préférais je préférais qu'on mette en
place une taxe carbone sur les
importations les plus lointaines.
Et de ce point de vue là, vous voyez
bien que la taxe carbone aux frontières
européenne ou nationale qui est un
projet
aujourd'hui assez communément partagé
pas par tout le monde mais à peu près,
c'est l'équivalent d'une TVA sur les
importations hein. et parfaitement ce
dont on a besoin économiquement et
écologiquement. Donc là, on a les deux.
Et bien si vous faites ça, vous voyez
bien que vous pouvez pas signer les
accords de libre échange.
Voilà, et que l'OMC, vous pouvez dire au
revoir, même si il y a une clause dans
l'OMC. J'avais fait cette étude là
puisque j'ai défendu
la démondialisation il y a maintenant 10
ans quand j'étais enfin j'ai défendu
depuis toujours hein quand j'étais jeune
député aussi. C'est le made in France,
c'est-à-dire euh on consomme ce qu'on
produit le plus possible. C'est une
vision purement kénésienne de l'économie
tout simplement. Il n'y a rien
d'innovant. Je dois vous dire que euh
quand on regarde le lien qui existe
entre l'écologie et l'économie, Nicolas
Hullot a parfaitement raison de dire on
peut pas être pour le libre échange,
ouvrir les frontières et en même temps
l'écologie, ça n'a aucun sens. Donc il
faut taxer les transports lointains. Par
exemple tout le fret maritime,
il faut remettre des droits de douane.
Il faut créer la taxe carbone, mais tu
as un prix carbone sur l'industrie et
l'industrie d'importation d'abord pour
que notre industrie soit compétitive.
C'est ça qu'il faut faire.
On cherche on cherche la personne qui va
le faire. Ça, je suis d'accord un peu
avec vous.
C'est que on a l'appareil mais on n pas
l'organe. C'est ça ? Je sais pas c'est
quoi votre votre phrase.
J'ai pas de phrase.
Si si vous avez
Si si vous avez un petit truc qui a fait
marrer euh le Sénat là. Je vais vous la
retrouver. Bon, pas un détail. Là, vous
avez fini. Vous voulez plus vous engager
en politique ? C'est terminé. Vous vous
positionnez pas en vous ne jugez pas vos
collègues d'autre parties. Vous allez
lancer un business sur le miel bleu,
blanc ruche.
J'ai créé une marque avec des
apiculteurs
et créer une marque équitable.
Combien vous touchez ? Pour l'instant
zéro. Moi moi
comment vous gagnez votre vie maintenant
?
Ah bah c'est assez simple, j'ai créé six
entreprises.
Donc je me débrouille pour faire du
conseil dans l'entreprise qui finance la
création des autres. Donc
combien vous gagnez ?
Écoutez, je gagne mieux ma vie que quand
j'étais au gouvernement. Au
gouvernement, je gagnais 8000 € par
mois.
Je pense que je suis au-dessus en ce
moment, même si ça marie net. Ah bah oui
oui.
Pas
phobie fiscale.
Non, je paye mes impôts. Je suis très
fier de payer mes impôt et et c'est
normal. Voilà.
Quand quand quand on vous reproche
mais je pourrais vous dire un mot sur la
question des marques équitables. On a
créé bleu blancruche
avec des apiculteurs
et on a décidé de faire une chose parce
que aujourd'hui euh il y a un
effondrement de l'apiculture en France.
pour des raisons environnementales mais
pas seulement aussi économique. Car vous
avez quand on regarde la géopolitique de
ce produit-là qui est le nectar fabuleux
issu du travail des enzymes des abeilles
qui est le miel, vous avez une
géopolitique, une cartographie
absolument extraordinaire.
Il y a eu une enquête de la Commission
européenne et d'UFC que choisir qui a
démontré qu'il y avait un tiers à peu
près des premiers prix de la grande
distribution en Europe et en France qui
contenait du miel frolaté, c'est-à-dire
du sirop de sucre vendu au prix du miel
et qui en fait sont conçus dans les
grandes usines à miel artificiel
chinoises
qui cassent le prix du miel en mettant
du sucre indétectable et se retrouve
mélangé par du commerce euh de la grande
distribution. Vous avez aujourd'hui des
conditionneurs qui sont des mélangeurs
et vous avez sur tous les pots de miel
mélange Union européenne hors Union
européenne, ce qui veut dire miel
planétaire finalement. En fait,
là-dedans, vous avez une chance sur
trois que ce soit du sirop de sucre venu
de Chine,
détection par la Commission européenne
UFC que choisir une association de
consommateurs. Donc nous, on a dit au
consommateurs, écoutez, nous on va vous
tracer le miel, on va le garantir
origine France, on va mieux payer
l'apiculteur, donc on va acheter le miel
chez lui entre 5 et 18 % plus cher et en
contrepartie, il va augmenter son nombre
de ruches, c'est-à-dire organiser le
repeuplement. Donc si tous ceux qui
veulent consommer du miel origine France
Garantie avec le nom de l'apiculteur sur
le pot, ben il prennent
bleublancruche.fr
sur le site internet, ils pourront
trouver ces miels. Alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un voyage
gustatif à travers tous les miels de
France parce que en fait l'abeille fait
parler la plante, la caia des vauges,
la bruyère des landes, le tiul de
Bourgogne, la fleur de printemps. Voilà.
Donc cette entreprise est une entreprise
qui maintenant réalise euh qui est sur
une trajectoire de 400000 € de chiffre
d'affaires. Peut-être qu'on fera même
encore plus. C'est la première année
pleine, hein. Donc on est très content.
Les consommateurs nous suivent, nous
écoutent, ils comprennent euh la mission
que nous remplissons, y compris pour
leur compte. Et donc bah je lance
au courant qu'en Chine, c'est des
ouvriers maintenant qui font la
pollinisation.
Oui, mais vous savez l'abeille elle rend
un service gratuit
qui a été évalué à 150 milliards
d'euros.
Le fait même d'aller butiner chercher le
pollen et le nectar. Le nectar par le
jabot et le pollen par les pâtes
arrières. C'est les plotes sur les pâtes
arrières. Vous
faites bien les pâtes arrières ?
Je les fait bien. Bon et ces abeilles
euh rendent un service gratuit en allant
se nourrir et en allant nourrir la
colonie.
Donc c'est ça n'a pas de sens d'aller
polliniser. Si on si on pollinise d'une
autre façon, ça n'a aucun sens. Mieux
vaut défendre la biodiversité. Il a nous
la France a vu disparaître 80 % de ses
insectes en 30 ans.
Quand on vous dit bleu blanc bleu blanc
ruche, c'est bien c'est des ruches de
repeuplement. Hm.
On vous objecte que vous allez mettre
une pression sur les les abeilles
sauvages en en mettant beaucoup de de
d'abeilles. Euh
vous savez, alors je il faut il faut
regarder les choses de façon
complémentaire.
Vous connaissiez la la phrase d'Instein
sur les abeilles ? Oui, enfin, elle est
prêtée à Einstein, je ne sais pas si
elle est d'Instein, mais elle est très
juste. Euh oui, pourquoi Einstein a dit
en où on prétend qu'Einstein aurait dit
qu'en 4 ans, si on perdait euh les
abeilles, l'humanité ne survivrait pas.
C'est pas tout à fait faux parce que les
abeilles sont responsables de la
pollinisation de 35 % de l'alimentation
humaine. C'est tous les fruits et
légumes, hormis les pommes de terre et
euh les céréales. Bon, vous enlevez ça
35 % de l'alimentation humaine avec la
population sur la planète, imaginez ce
qui se passe, les chaos, les guerres,
les affrontements. Donc je pense qu'on
va au devant de graves difficultés. Donc
défendre l'abeille, c'est défendre la
survie euh de l'espèce humaine et
attachée.
Et donc euh euh les abeilles sauvages ne
sont pas en compétition avec les
abeilles domestiques. Euh pourquoi ?
Parce que euh d'abord il y en a plus
assez. Donc plus il y en a, mieux c'est
qu'elle soit sauvage ou domestique. Et
surtout l'abeille domestique a plus de
chance de survivre dans le monde hostile
aujourd'hui déclaré à l'abeille.
D'ailleurs, je dis souvent, on se on
s'intéresse pas assez à l'apiculteur qui
est le gardien des abeilles qui les
protège, qui les soigne, qui les nourrit
quand il y a pas de de plantes. Et donc
le gardien des abeilles qui est
l'apiculteur, c'est la garantie de
survie de l'abeille. Donc n'opposons pas
l'abeille sauvage. Et d'ailleurs, il y a
beaucoup d'apiculteurs qui élèvent des
abeilles sauvages. Donc ils ne sont pas
tout à fait sauvages mais ils les
élèvent. Donc je pense que c'est un
débat qui a été tranché
scientifiquement. Vous avez au muséum
d'histoire naturelle, vous avez des
grands penseurs, des grands
scientifiques qu'on dit "Ce n'est pas
l'un contre l'autre, c'est l'un et
l'autre et on a besoin des deux". Ai-je
répondu ?
Oui. Je vais vous poser une autre
question qui n'a rien à voir. Les flux
migratoires,
on on voit la France qui n'accorde pas
euh de port à des associations qui qui
euh vont chercher les gens qui se noient
dans la Méditerranée.
Euh,
on fait comment avec les flux
migratoires que ce soit économique ou
climatique ?
Bah, on va avoir de toute façon là, on
est en train de payer la facture de ne
pas avoir développé
l'Afrique. On a mis tous nos
investissements en Chine. C'est absurde.
On aurait pu les mettre en Afrique,
faire énormément de choses.
Donc on sait ce qui nous reste à faire,
travailler avec les pays de départ
et et il y a du travail avec ce qui se
passe dans tous les pays
du nord jusqu'au sud de l'Afrique. Mais
il n'y a pas d'autres solution.
Est-ce que Est-ce que on va voir des
murs srigés en Europe ?
Quel mur ? Les gens meurent en
Méditerranée. C'est pas un mur, c'est
une mer.
Euh les murs, c'est
dans un pays qui a connu 10 ans de crise
où il est extrêmement difficile pour des
catégories entières de la population de
survivre,
beaucoup pensent qu'il n'est pas
raisonnable de d'abandonner le contrôle
des flux migratoires. Toute nation a
toujours contrôlé ces flux migratoires.
Après, on peut décider quelle est la
taille de ces flux. Mais c'est normal
qu'une nation veuille contrôler ses
flux. Ça me paraît être l'élément
Régistre Debré a parlé qui était qui
était le collaborateur de François
Mitteran a fait les loges de la
frontière. Il a dit la frontière c'est
la limite.
Quand vous éduquez vos enfants, vous
fixez une limite. Quand vous discutez
avec le système financier, vous leur
dites "Aprenez des limites dans votre
manière de faire."
Donc une société raisonnable, c'est une
société où il y a des limites.
Alors question d'internet, pourriez-vous
lui demander combien il touche de
subvention pour ces entreprises
écologiques ?
Zéro. Zéro subvention. Ne demandons pas
de subvention.
Nous demandons pas de subvention pour
une raison simple, c'est que nous
faisons la démonstration que le modèle
économique et des marques équitables et
rentables. D'ailleurs, nous avons des
investisseurs exclusivement privés.
Alors, l'INRA est entré euh
euh aux capital de l'une d'entre elles,
mais on lui a donner les actions.
C'est nous qui avons fait euh cadeau à
Linra en contrepartie de son apport
scientifique et technologique.
Une entreprise qui est subventionnée est
une entreprise qui est morte, hein, par
définition, hein,
parce qu'elle ne peut pas
bah elle ne peut pas survivre. Ça veut
dire qu'elle n'a pas d'avenir.
C'est ça.
Ouais. Bah oui euh c'est difficile quoi.
Vous comprenez tout de suite que si vous
dépendez de subsid public, vous ne
pouvez pas euh vous ne pouvez pas
trouver rentabilité donc de survie
d'espace de survie économique. Pourquoi
? Enfin, excusez-moi, euh c'est c'est
c'est je c'est un rappel sain de la part
d'un ancien ministre de l'économie. Non,
je sais pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
réindustrialiser le pays et pour
empêcher les délocalisations ?
Alors, il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire. D'abord
euh
garder ce qu'on a, ça renvoie à la
conversation précédente.
Euh rapatrier ce qu'on a perdu. Exemple,
racheter le nucléaire de chez Alstom, on
peut le faire, c'est rentable. Euh ça
nous revient naturellement. Les chinois
général électrique sont en train de
vendre aux Chinois
l'ancienne usine Nerpic qui était chez
Alstom qui sont les turbines hydro
hydraulique pour les barrages. Je
rappelle que Halstom avait 25 % des
turbines
hydrauliques dans le monde. On était
leader mondial. C'est ça qu'on a vendu.
C'était d'ailleurs dans les
co-entreprises
énergie renouvelable parce que les
barrages c'est du renouvelable. C'est de
l'énergie propre.
Ça faut racheter.
Donc j'ai croisé monsieur le maire à la
sortie de mon audition au Sénat, c un
hasard. Je suis dit mais il faut y
aller. Trouver l'argent. Vous avez la
BPI à quoi elle sert ? Nous on vous
trouvera des fonds qui sont prêts à
investir parce qu'ils y croient tout
simplement. Pas dans la France seulement
dans cette dans ces dans ces grandes
activités euh économiques qui sont
d'ailleurs profitables. Donc qu'est-ce
qu'on attend ? Donc rapatrier ce qu'on a
perdu
et puis créer ce qu'on a pas. où ce
qu'on a plus. Et là, tout est à faire.
Alors, j'avais créé 34 plans industriels
dans tous les secteurs où on pouvait,
bon malheureusement mon successeur,
monsieur Macron, n'a pas donné de suite,
mais dans les biotechnologies, dans le
cloud sécurisé européen, dans la filière
construction bois, dans l'avion
électrique, par exemple, je vais vous
donner un exemple, l'ancien directeur
recherche développement d'Airbus euh
avec qui j'avais créé le plan
industriel, qui pilotait le plan
industriel pour compte d'erbus, des
futurs avions électriques qui aura un
avenir comme les voitures électriques.
Euh euh bah Airbus a arrêté de faire
l'avion électrique. Lui, il l'a repris à
son compte. Je suis allé le voir au
salon du Bourget, il est en train de
sortir le prototype, il va bientôt
traverser la Manche. Donc ça avance mais
c'est initiativ privée. Où est le
gouvernement ? Voyez donc ça c'est ce
qu'on avait fait. On avait fait des
pilotages privés de programmes publics
avec de l'argent public et de l'argent
privé. Donc unir les forces.
Deuxièmement, le financement de tout ça.
On a euh un des taux les plus élevés
d'épargne au monde grâce à la
défiscalisation de l'assurance vie. Moi,
je propose que 5 10 % je ne sais pas à
débattre avec euh les compagnies
d'assurance de l'assurance vie
défiscalisé qui est le qui en fait ce
sont les fonds de c'est les fonds de
pension français. l'assurance vie
servent à investir en France et non pas
dans les fonds souverains, Singapourien,
je ne sais où et servent à investir en
France dans toutes les entreprises qui
se créent non côté et cetera. On peut
trouver 50 milliards à investir.
Après, je vous donne cet exemple, mais
il y a de l'argent, il y a des idées en
France. Vous avez des une nouvelle
génération d'entrepreneurs, je les
fréquente beaucoup dans dans mon
travail. Vous avez une nouvelle
génération d'entrepreneurs
qui inventent des modèles économiques
géniaux. Pourquoi ?
Bah par exemple, vous avez une
entreprise que j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle 1083 qui est qui a été fondée
par deux frères de Grenoble, les frères
Urièz. Ils ont décidé de faire refaire
des jeans en France de A à Z. D'ailleurs
1083, ça veut dire parce que le jean est
fait à moins de 1083 km de votre
domicile, c'est-à-dire euh le la
distance la plus éloignée entre les les
points les plus éloignés de l'hexagone.
1083 km, Menton, Brest. Bon,
ils ont reconstitué la filière, créé des
emplois de confection, de production.
Comment ils l'ont fait ? Bah, ils ont
supprimé la distribution et ils ont fait
un modèle de vente sur internet et ils
sont remis. à financer, à créer des
emplois dans la production et non plus
seulement dans le marketing ou la
distribution. Et ils ont un résultat des
résultats extraordinaires. Donc on peut
leur rendre hommage tirer chapeau si on
faisait
10 20 30 50 100 entreprises de cette
nature mais ils ont racheté une filature
qui était en faillite. Ils ont sauvé les
emplois parce qu'ils ont réappris les
métiers du tissage. Ils réapprennent. La
France doit réapprendre les métiers
qu'elle a abandonné.
C'est un travail d'une génération, il
faut se retrousser les manches, tous s'y
mettre. Moi, je le fais à ma manière.
Nous, on défend le revenu des
agriculteur. Par exemple, on est en
train de créer une nouvelle marque
équitable dans la glace bio. Pourquoi la
glace bio ? D'abord, parce que la glace
aujourd'hui, 4 milliards de marché, les
français consomment 4 milliards de glac.
Euh c'est des produits chimiques
essentiellement industriels. Et vous
n'avez absolument pas de glace bio sur
le marché. Vous avez 1,2 % du marché en
glace bio.
Nous avons décidé d'installer des
sorbetières chez les éleveurs laitiers
qui sont en difficulté et surtout eux
vont fabriquer des petits ateliers de
production de glace bio à partir de leur
lait bio où on va acheter le lait
beaucoup plus cher et permettre de les
rémunérer pour leur travail. Et tout ça
formé par un directeur technique, un
meilleur ouvrier de France glacier.
Voilà notre Et vous savez qui est venu
investir dans ce projet des Japonais.
Donc on peut le faire. Voilà, si tous
les gars du monde, en tout cas ceux de
France qui sont là sur le territoire
pouvaient réinventer notre pays, je
pense que on a des ressources
fabuleuses. Les étrangers, le monde
entier nous envie. Il nous parle de la
France. Nous, nous sommes nos pires
procureurs. Donc moi, j'ai envie de
garder cet optimisme et de le défendre.
Alors, vous avez de l'optimisme, on va
parler crise financière maintenant.
On voit émerger de plus en plus de
papiers qui nous annoncent l'apocalypse
financière pour dans pas très longtemps
parce que le système est basé sur une
fonction exponentielle un peu de c'est
de la cavalerie un peu partout. Est-ce
que vous avez un avis sur ça en tant
qu'ancien ministre des finances ?
Je n'étais pas ministre des finances
mais de l'économie mais j'ai un avis.
Oui.
Euh oui, parce que rien, aucune des
réglementations qui auraient dû être
prise
euh donc des interdictions hein, des
mesures assez dures qui avaient été
préconisées par euh beaucoup de penseurs
de ces questions-là, hein. Euh aucune
n'a été prise.
Euh
on a durci la législation sur les
banques pour éviter les crises
systémiques, c'est-à-dire les système de
propagation des futures crises. Mais les
bulles, elles sont là. Par ailleurs, les
politiques de quantitative easing des
banques centrales
ont déversé des milliards dans la
sébille du système financier. Donc a
servi finalement le système financier,
pas du tout l'économie réelle.
Donc nous sommes en danger.
Euh j'aimerais que les gouvernements
s'emparent de ça pour finalement
crever les bulles les unes après les
autres. Bulles immobilières parci aux
États-Unis, c'est la bulle de la dette
des prêts étudiants.
En Chine, il y a des bulles
immobilières, ils ferment, ils ont
construit des des des montagnes, enfin
des des des villes entières qui sont
vides.
Ghost Town. Coast Towns,
des villes fantômes. Voilà. Donc les
gouvernements, leur responsabilité
aujourd'hui et les banques centrales et
le FMI d'ailleurs, c'est de crever les
bulles les unes après les autres. Donc
euh
Mario Dragy baisse les taux,
il a pas le choix. S'il les augmente,
s'il les augmente,
game over,
on se retrouve en difficulté.
Vous avez pas ces difficultés, ça
pourrait se matérialiser comment ? avec
des banqu euh avec des gens qui qui font
la le risque que nous courons euh
essentiellement à cause du shadow
banking puisque vous employez des mots
anglo-saxons,
dark pool, chose comme ça.
Euh c'est-à-dire finalement la partie
euh
à l'ombre du système financier qui a euh
conservé euh c'est environ 60 % du
système financier mondial, hein. Il y a
il y a des livres qui ont été écrits par
des anciens membres d'autorité
indépendante financière
qui qui explique très bien ce mécanisme.
Donc c'est ça qui c'est de là que vient
le danger. Il y a pas de réglementation
qui a été prise sur le sur le sujet et
c'est là qu'il faudrait le faire. Là il
y a une urgence par exemple. Il une
urgence
le fait d'avoir un ancien banquier
d'affaires en tant que président de la
République, c'est bien, c'est pas bien
pour gérer ce type d'urgence. Écoutez,
je vous ai dit que je ne répondais pas
aux questions personnelles
sur Macron,
sur quiconque.
C'est notre président. Vous avez voté
pour lui ou pas ?
Euh, ça ne vous regarde pas. Je ne
révèle pas ce que je vote dans
l'isoloir.
Ah, il est dur, il est dur en affaire.
On arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview.
Est-ce que vous avez des sujets que vous
voulez aborder avec nous ? Ben écoutez,
d'abord euh non, je crois que si j'ai
répondu à vos internautes euh et à vos
préoccupations
euh je pense que nous avons entre les
mains euh des ressources fabuleuses
et que la France a besoin d'unité,
c'est-à-dire que les gens s'unissent
pour mettre en œuvre des projets
derrière un derrière quelance France,
excusez-moi monsieur, je termine ma
phrase si vous me permettez. La France a
besoin de se mettre en mode projet.
Voilà. Et c'est pas un projet, c'est des
projets. C'est un peu comme ça que je
sens la période et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que moi-même tous les jours je monte
des projets. Donc vous en entendrez
bientôt parler. En tout cas, merci de
m'avoir permis. Est-ce que je peux faire
une page de publicité ? Non. Après après
la dernière après après la dernière
question c'est laisser un conseil aux
jeunes génération
quelque chose d'impérissable une
bouteille à la mer et après on pourra
faire ce que vous voulez.
Alors aux jeunes génération je leur
dirai
unissez-vous avec des gens qui sont vos
contraires, qui sont vos différents, qui
n'ont pas euh vos origines, votre
histoire, votre géographie, votre
religion, votre couleur de peau, peu
importe. Et monter des projets ensemble,
vous les réussirez. Rêvez le monde comme
disait Oscar Wild, faites en sorte que
vos rêves soient les plus grands
possibles pour qu'il en rêve il en reste
toujours quelque chose. Voilà. Et si
toutes les personnes qui nous ont écouté
veulent soutenir le repeuplement en
abeille de France, c'est sur bleuche.fr.
Merci. Bleublancruche.fr.
En vous remerciant infiniment
pour vos sympathiques et provoquantes
questions.
Arnaud Mondtebourg toujours l'action
sœur du rêve. Merci d'être venu nous
voir et un jour on abordera le
renoncement de Saint-Pierre tous les
deux. Bonne soirée.
[Musique]